since 1941 jeeps have been taking people
everywhere through deserts jungles or
even peaceful country roads the company
has a very clear standpoint cart
estimate Oscar says he recently heard a
radio ad only achieved from cheap is a
real cheap we'll take a closer look
whether a Jeep Cherokee keeps that
promise the current generation of the
Cherokee has been on the market since
2013 its handling isn't typical of an
American car or an SUV Montes is really
pleased with how quickly and agile the
Cherokee takes curves he says you never
have the feeling that the chassis is
slipping out of control or that the car
under or over steers well-made says
Montes and he likes how responsive the
steering is our test car a Cherokee
Limited has an Italian 2.2 liter
four-cylinder diesel engine with 147
kilowatts of power and 440 Newton meters
of torque the Cherokee has a 9 speed
automatic transmission made by the
German company
CF Cherokee is also offered with a 3.2
liter gasoline engine but Montes thinks
the diesel is a better choice for
everyday use in Europe he does wish the
diesel had a bit more Verve it takes
longer than he'd like for the car to
pick up speed Machado but all in all
he's pleased especially with the
ergonomics of the Cherokees seats
Yaman you feel very comfortable in them
he says even on a long drive the
striking design feature in front is the
Jeep's typical grille with seven
vertical air intakes the extravagant
design of the split front headlights is
very striking Monta says that's not his
taste but maybe the repairs are cheaper
when a stone or branch breaks only part
of a headlight
Matas has less to criticize about the
side profile and rear design now Montes
checks out the trunk he's not pleased
that the loading sill is so elevated
almost hip high for him that means he'd
have to live luggage or cargo chest high
to load it on the plus side the mat with
a nice carpet on the one side can't be
turned over with its rubber side up so
if you pick up some rustic garden
decorations in the forest
you don't dirty everything up without
the mechana sign
the dashboard makes a solid impression
the seats are almost like armchairs you
don't slide around even if the car tilts
next to the automatic gear shift is a
select terrain switch to adapt the
powertrain and stability control to
various Road or off-road conditions for
example if you drive on sand and mud
we'll test that after all that's what a
driver expects a jeep to handle
it's peeping the whole time complaints
montes till he shuts off the warning
tone here then he continues driving he's
not so sure his test car can handle this
so he backs out the limited variants
fifteen point seven centimeters ground
clearance it's not enough for really
rough terrain mother says he's too
uncertain here and doesn't want to
damage the car some terrain is too rough
even for a jeep practical in such
situations he says is this 8.4 inch
monitor showing what the rear view
camera sees even if bushes block the
right and left hand mirrors you still
know where you're going for money in fat
so is the cherokee limited despite its
all-wheel drive more suited for the
asphalt jungle than for real jungle
phenom Oliver Montes is the Cherokee is
fully adequate for normal forest paths
but if you want to tackle tougher
terrain he recommends the trailhawk
variant because it's select terrain
switch offers a fifth choice rock and
it's much more capable of off-road
driving than the limited